mainly because of the types of work that
I do I get a lot of people who come to
me with questions about how to study
philosophy and one of the recurring
motifs that I see creating problems for
a lot of people has to do with studying
in a let's call it
chronological manner so meaning
beginning at at the start and ending at
the end point whatever that happens to
be now that's rather difficult to do for
a discipline that has you know not only
Millennia of history but isn't quite
finished yet philosophy is still ongoing
but there's a lot of people out there
who either have come up with this idea
themselves or they've been told by other
people perhaps other Scholars that what
they really ought to to do if they want
to study philosophy in the the best way
or an adequate way is that they have to
begin with the presocratic and then they
have to move on through philosophy or
maybe they begin with PL or maybe they
begin somewhere else and they have to do
things in a you know
historical uh this came first this came
next this came next sort of way there's
no problem calling that
chronological and I'm going to say that
there's there's nothing inherently wrong
or bad about doing this although as
you're going to see there's some
problems that may be insurmountable
depending on how strict you want to be
in what you conceive of studying
philosophy
chronologically to be and it is one way
to structure your your own self-directed
study or to structure a curriculum of
philosophy it's not the worst way right
I suppose much worse than that would
just be sort of picking books off the
shelf at random and reading them and
maybe not even reading the whole book
but just reading a bit of it but it it
isn't necessarily the best way to study
philosophy either and you know I think
we have to Begin by distinguishing two
different senses in which you could
study philosophy chronologically so the
first one would be let's call it the
grand sweep you begin with the
presocratic and then you move on to
Socrates largely through Plato but of
course you wouldn't want to leave zenfon
out and then you get Aristotle and then
where do you go from there and you try
to go all the way up to the present and
you could say that there are some
projects out there that are trying to do
the history of Phil philosophy like that
for example the podcast history of
philosophy without any gaps which you
know I don't know if they have any gaps
or not I haven't looked at it for a
while and you could also talk about a
more limited scope where you're going to
study a particular
philosopher chronologically that is
begin with his or her earliest works and
then move in through those early Works
into the middle works and work all the
way to the end point of their their life
their their curriculum what it is that
they're offering to the world and that's
not a bad idea to do you could also do
this with a movement of philosophy like
you could be like well we're going to
study the utilitarian so obviously we
begin with Jeremy Bentham well maybe not
so obvious because Hume talks about
utility and so do other people before
him but let's just say we begin with you
know the official founder of the
doctrine so we do benem and then you
know we look at some other minor figures
then we get to John Stewart Mill and
Henry swick and then all the other
utilitarians that wind up being
important in the 20th and 21st century
right so that's that's possible to do as
a mode of
study so before we look at whether this
is actually
feasible um is this the best way to go
is this actually a good way to go and I
do want to say there are some possible
advantages to looking at things
chronologically so you know one is that
there tends to be a coherent history so
you're probably going to get more out of
studying Emmanuel Kant by looking at
what he was doing before he had his
critical turn after his you know
Awakening from his dogmatic Slumber by
reading Hume and then you know reading
say the first critique and the
proma and then moving to the later stuff
you know the moral philosophy the
critique of judgment that's it's not a
bad way to go you're probably going to
learn a good bit by looking at things in
that sort of light or we could think
about Renee day cart right uh rules for
the direction of the mind and then you
know we get uh the world which doesn't
get published but the discourse does and
then we get the meditations and the
objections and replies and principles of
philosophy and you know towards the end
of his life correspondence with Princess
Elizabeth and the passions of the Soul
okay that's not a bad way to go you can
actually see the development of ideas
taking place and you also get to see
like who is influencing not just that
philosopher but the people that they are
engaging with uh um you know you get to
see the sort of common language across a
group of thinkers that's shared you know
Common vocabulary that's being developed
you know it's a way to understand what
some people have called an intellectual
tradition so it's not there's nothing
bad about approaching things
chronologically but I do want to say
that there are going to be some some
issues some problems that you do have to
face and the first one is the problem I
think this probably suggests itself to
everybody the problem of actually being
systematic and comprehensive if you're
going to study philosophy just Western
philosophy don't even worry about
nonwestern
philosophy just stick with the stuff
that happens in Europe for a a long time
or in the Mediterranean let's
say well there's a lot of figures
there's a lot of thinkers we have a lot
of texts and the more that you study
when you first begin like let's say you
take an internal philosophy class and
your teacher gets up there and they give
you a Spiel and they're like yeah first
there was this there were these
presocratic we're going to look at them
a little bit you know and then there was
this Socrates guy and Plato is his
student Aristotle is his student and
then we get the helenistic period and
you know you've got epicurian and stoics
and Skeptics and then you know
eventually Christianity comes on the
scene and that you know that things kind
of depending on what story they're
telling go into decline or it gets
better whatever and then we get into the
medieval period and maybe that's the
Dark Ages the whole time or maybe it's
actually a time of great intellectual
ferment and all of that well there's a
lot of thinkers in there and so if
you're going to be
comprehensive in how you're being
chronological you really can't skip all
of these people you can't afford to say
well you know they were the neoplatonist
we'll read platin and that's good enough
no there's all these other thinkers and
there's also the middle Pless that you
you should read like Plutarch and
alcinous right yeah that's that's that's
a problem there um and you know along
with this we can say well how do we
actually know who we're supposed to read
well we got to rely on some sort of
narrative so if you're going to be
chronological it's not as if you have to
buy into somebody's history 100% but you
got to begin from somewhere so who are
you going to think is worth fitting in
some of the narratives that we have out
there are kind of biased or frankly
outdated from you know they bad history
that's been left behind by good
historians or there's huge gaps so think
for example about the prevalent thing of
saying well you know we've got these
ancient thinkers and then Christianity
comes on the scene in the west and it
all kind of goes into decline but we do
have a couple smart guys like Augustine
and aquinus and then after that modern
philosophy with you know Renee day cart
and maybe Hobs is also in there and
maybe makavelli and you know Spinosa and
these these continental rationalists and
British empiricists and blah blah blah
right I mean you've all heard these
stories or perhaps you haven't yet right
but they're not adequate narratives of
what actually took place it's way
Messier way more complicated there's
lots of really cool stuff happening
during the end of antiquity and moving
into the Middle
Ages the medievals didn't even know they
were medievals until much much later on
actually they didn't know it's their
historians centuries later who who know
that so I mean this is kind of a a
problem we have another big problem you
know so let's say you actually are some
sort of independently wealthy person who
doesn't have to work for a living and
you can read all these people in the
ancient period and the medieval period
and the early modern period and of
course the Renaissance and you know we
get up to the 19th 20th 21st century
there's so many philosophers to read you
think of it as like a funnel right where
it's going along for a while and then it
just gets
huge who are you going to read
I mean just to read all of the people
who have worked
within the tradition of say Continental
philosophy anglo-american Continental
philosophy we'll leave out the people
who are doing it in Scandinavia and in
other places just that there's too many
people for you to possibly ever read
your way through and we continually
adding to it so that's a bit of a
problem as well um you know we we can
also talk about the people who've been
left out of the story if you go to older
histories of philosophy I'll give you a
prime example of this women in early
modern philosophy you can get
contemporary uh histories of philosophy
gring is a prime example where most of
the important women's Scholars who were
acknowledged as such during their time
are just completely passed over or they
have a footnote or maybe a page or so
when really they deserve much more you
know Maria Stell and Margaret Cavendish
and uh you know Mary walstone craft a
week AG go on and on and on and on and
on so there's there's parts of the
chronological story that you might have
to do a bit of digging to actually find
and it's not just for women in early
modern philosophy we've got Medieval
women as as well just not quite as many
that whose text we we have so that's a
set of problems right there another uh
big problem is
that if you're being really strict about
this I'm going to study philosophy in a
chronological way I'm going to read the
fragments that we have of the PRI
socratics and then I'm going to read you
know Plato and we we'll read some zenfon
because you get Socrates through him as
well and we'll read some Aristotle and
then we'll move into these helenistic
thinkers and you know Roman Imperial
thinkers there are so many of them that
if you actually want to do a good job
and read through all of them you'll
probably never in your lifetime get out
of the ancient period and into the
medieval period so you're going to have
to skip somebody you're going to have to
leave somebody behind and that's going
to be a decision that you make without
fully knowing because you haven't read
them whether you're leaving some jewels
on the table so to speak and sweeping
them away um you could say well I'll
just start later I'll start at the
medieval period or early modern period
same problem if you're going to actually
be comprehensive in your chronology
there are so many thinkers that you
probably won't get through all of them
another big problem and this is a a side
issue there is no agreed upon definition
of what counts as philosophy and you
know what its nature is what its goals
are what its objects are um you know how
it develops and what is not philosophy
what is rhetoric or theology or pick
whatever other discipline you want and
you can say oh but I have some well
you've got some but those are only local
they're not Global there is no consensus
the understanding of what philosophy is
has changed many times so you've got to
figure out if you're going to be
comprehensive about this in your
chronological approach who gets in who
doesn't get in because you don't have a
lot of extra time to read people that
aren't philosophy then right so that's
going to be a bit of a problem and we
also have this
issue of uh
contemporaries how do you in fact decide
who came first and who came after when
you've got people doing philosophical
work at the same time so if we doing the
early modern period does Hobs come
before
deart does should decart come first and
then Hobs after what about Blaze
Pascal what about and we could go on and
on and on about these thinkers or you
know let's say we're doing the uh
Imperial Roman period Okay so we've got
you know Plutarch and epicus and dioc
christum and they're all important
thinkers but they're all flourishing
around the same time who who should we
study first should we maybe do like
early works by them oh that's kind of
tough to do because epicus didn't
actually write his discourses Aryan
recorded them right we could go on and
on and on with similar sorts of
problems um if we're going to stick with
just a
philosopher or a movement of philosophy
well how do we do that for example with
Plato there's lots of theories about
well this dialogue came before this
dialogue those are just theories we
don't actually have a chronology for
Plato's Works what we have are a bunch
of theory
dependent um Frameworks out there for
what order you ought to study or read
these in and those are by the way
different those are mostly from you know
Germans in the 19th century and then you
know later people in the 20th century
those are different from what the actual
platonists prescribed for people to
study them in the order is is different
what about with Aristotle did the Udan
ethics come before the ni McCain ethics
a lot of Scholars think so we don't know
we're not sure you know so what
chronology should you have for that you
know and then it gets more complicated
yet if they wrote some letters let's
take ansom of Canterbury for example who
had a a very cool letter collection that
he had deliberately preserved or let's
take Sena right he wrote a ton of
letters as well but he also wrote a
whole bunch of work works so do you have
to read the first works first and then
if a letter was written in between that
work and another work do you got to read
that letter before you move on to the
next work you can't read the whole
letter collection right because it's
over the course of the author's life
again the you can see the Ridiculousness
of this if you're going to be very
strict about this you're going to get
yourself into all sorts of problems and
that's with letters what about notes
what about sketches what about outline
for things it's all a lot of trouble and
so here's what I'm going to say if you
want to try to approach things in a
roughly chronological way I'm not going
to discourage you I'm just going to say
you know the stricter you get about that
the more comprehensive and systematic
you get about this the more you're going
to run into these problems that are
inevitably going to arise for you and
could discourage you and I don't want
you to get discouraged I want you to
study philosophy I want you to get as
much as you can out of studying the
thinkers and texts and topics in this
field that I have devoted now more than
half of my lifetime to because I found
it valuable so I don't want to
discourage you what I will say is that
when you're really studying philosophy
in any sort of serious way you're
inevitably going to be selective so
don't don't you know feel bad about the
fact that you can't get to everybody or
that you didn't do enough attention to
this particular Century of philosophy
and you're also going to be what we
could call iterative that means you're
going over things again and again you
don't read all of Plato's works and now
you've got PL down and mastered and you
never go back and read it again you're
going to have to go back and reread and
when you do it's rewarding now you're
going to take yourself out of your
chronological order when you do that
because you're not going to make it you
know over the course of your lifetime
from everything in the beginning to
everything at the end you know and then
the next uh you know 30 40 years go back
and start again no you you're going to
take certain figures and go back to them
over and over again I read Rene cart's
meditations at least once a year in part
because I teach it every year I read
through most of Plato's um dialogues
once a year I read through some texts uh
only once every 10 years and some text
uh close to every
month that's normal in philosophy so I
think that um it's perfectly fine if
you're laboring under a feeling that oh
I'm not I'm not doing philosophy and and
the study of it right because I'm going
out of order or I haven't read
everything in this period so I can't
move on to the next take that weight off
your shoulders you don't have to place
that burden upon yourself and if there's
somebody out there who's telling you
that you're doing it wrong because you
haven't read all of these other thinkers
before you move on to the
next maybe you shouldn't be listening to
them at least on that point so uh I'll
encourage you if you want to do things
in chronological order try it out see
how far it gets you I'm not going to
legislate for you saying oh you must do
philosophy in this way I'm a pluralist
myself I think there's a lot of
legitimate ways to study philosophy I'm
just pointing out some of the problems
and you might even say paradoxes that
arise when you decide for yourself that
you're going to try to study philosophy
in a very comprehensive and
chronological
manner